each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a great pleasure to have you
Scott Aaronson
from MIT Scott is leader in research in
quantum computing is one day we NSF a
Waterman I award for top a young
scientist in a very popular blog and as
recently within a book which is
available and has been compared by say
Floyd to an open brain surgery I think
but I think he meant it as a compliment
always wonderful to have an excuse to
make the long journey down the road from
from MIT to come visit here so okay so
so actually you know I've spoken here
twice before about sort of more you know
specific technical things but since this
was there the colloquium I thought that
I would give sort of a more general talk
about you know it's something that's
been on my mind lately which is you know
so you think quantum computing is bunk
so so right so so so so let me start by
just you know reviewing some of some
basics about quantum computing I'm sure
you know some of you know this stuff you
know and then I'm going to talk about
okay you know what would it take sort of
to make quantum computing not work to
make it fail for some fundamental
physical reason and you know is that a
serious possibility that we should be
considering okay so sorry when I did a
Google image search for quantum computer
this was one of the first things that
came up that's apparently what they look
like so you know I'm as you can probably
tell I'm a theorist I'm not an engineer
so so my talk will will reflect that
I guess that in the middle was the is a
qubit or something but okay so so so you
know I I work on a quantum computing
theory most of the time but actually you
know when I first heard the idea of
quantum computing I think it was when I
read in New York Times article about it
as a teenager in you know 1996 or so and
you know my immediate reaction was this
is obvious garbage you know this is you
know people just keep you know coming
along with you know with ideas about you
know some miracle computer that could
you know do everything right and there's
always some catch there's always you
know something you know that that they
forgot the model that some resource
that's going to blow up exponentially as
you try to scale it up so you know so so
I decided you know it's a teenager that
I was going to read about this and just
just just to figure out what the catch
was okay but then I realized that in
order to do that you know I first had to
figure out what the deal was with
quantum mechanics itself okay and and
then you know if you know you haven't
done that then you know then then you
know you're in for a wild ride I guess
so okay so um you know um you know I
think the problem is you know of course
I had you know read books about it of
course I'd heard that while you does
both a particle and a wave and you know
cats are both you know alive and dead
right but you know it sounds all kind of
complicated and confusing right yeah
that's right that's right that's right
and and and you know and and and and you
know to hear it from the physicist if
you really want to understand the stuff
then you know you have to spend you know
maybe years and years you know studying
you know how to how to compute you know
the energy levels of you know of various
atoms and uh you know and actually
that's that's true you do have to study
that stuff if you're interested in you
know in in how to sort of explain the
you know the actual behavior of light
and of atoms and molecules okay but the
secret which I'll now let you in on is
that quantum mechanics is actually
unbelievably simple once you take the
physics out of it so
so I can just basically show you quantum
mechanics in one slide okay the one
sentence summary of it is that it is you
know it is what you'd inevitably get if
you tried to invent something which was
like probability theory but which
involved complex numbers instead of
non-negative real numbers okay so just
to elaborate a little bit so what is
probability theory right it's this
theory where you encapsulate your
knowledge about some system say that
could be in n different states by
assigning it a vector of probabilities
okay so you say the probability that
this system is in state I is equal to P
sub I okay and of course these
probabilities have to be non-negative
real numbers they have to add up to one
okay and then there's an evolution rule
so if the system undergoes some change
then you update your description of the
system by taking this vector of
probabilities and multiplying it by any
matrix that has the property that it
Maps any vector of probabilities to
another vector of probabilities okay
such a matrix as it's called a
stochastic matrix okay
so now quantum mechanics is just the
same thing except that you're you know
now we have to describe our knowledge of
a system at least sort of in the
simplest or sort of pure case by giving
it a vector of complex numbers okay so
you know basically you know a lot of
physics can be summarized by the by by
just you know the rule that that's sort
of in every situation where you would
think that the one norm is the only
thing that would make sense God instead
chooses the two norm okay
so again another another secret I'm
letting you in on okay so so so so it is
with quantum mechanics so so you know
you would think that you know like a
these probably you know these numbers
like you know in a Vic would go in a
vector here could only be not
non-negative reals well no we're gonna
let them be complex numbers okay
and now the rule is that they're two
norm has to be conserved so the meaning
the sum of the squares of the absolute
values of these numbers has to be one
okay and
the system you know if the system
undergoes evolution that corresponds it
is taking this vector of complex numbers
and multiplying it by any matrix that
maps unit vectors to unit vectors okay
and such a matrix is called a unitary
matrix alright so so it's sort of the
source of all the quantum weirdness or
you know all of the phenomena that you
know people talk about of you know the
uncertainty principle
you know entanglement all the thing
right any time someone tells you
something about you know weird behavior
of the quantum world that you know
differs from that of the classical world
you know either they're wrong or else
you know they you know whatever they're
describing can ultimately be understood
in terms of this phenomenon of
interference so this is simply the fact
that where is am probabilities are
always non-negative amplitudes or
complex numbers and so you know if you
you have you know and you may have to
you know to calculate the final
amplitude for first something to happen
you may have to add up a whole bunch of
terms and some of them may be positive
others may be negative others may be
pointing this way in that in the complex
plane and you know if they're pointing
in all different directions they could
cancel each other out okay and if so the
result will be that that you know the
corresponding event
well maybe not happen at all or will
happen with only very small probability
okay because the different ways that it
could have happened you know cancel each
other okay and so you can see that in
just you know the simplest quantum
system which is a single quantum bit or
qubit okay so you know we can because
you know the this you know they were
we're interested in unit vectors you
know they we can we can write you know
we can think of the states of one qubit
you know at least they're the ones with
real amplitudes only as just lying along
a circle okay so the zero state is the
horizontal okay by the way these
asymmetric brackets are called the Dirac
ket notation you know you get used to
them with time okay they're actually
really nice once you okay and you know
and and the one is
or in the orthogonal direction okay so
this is the vertical direction okay and
these correspond to just two possible
outcomes of a measurement on your system
okay that are perfectly distinguishable
so these could be like you know an
electron is either in its ground state
or its first excited state okay a photon
to be either polarized this way or
polarized that way okay they're just any
any two states of a system that can be
perfectly distinguished by a measurement
okay and then what quantum mechanics
says is that you know if you have that
then the system can also be in any
superposition of the states okay which
you know we write like alpha 0 plus beta
1 okay or you know like you could have
this 0 plus 1 over square root of 2 for
example you could also have minus 0 plus
1 over square root of 2 okay which is a
different superposition okay and now you
know for an example of interference
suppose we apply this unitary
transformation okay that just takes a
vector and rotates at 45 degrees
counterclockwise in the plane and you
know if you apply it once them you know
you map the 0 to the 0 plus 1 over root
2 you play a same operation a second
time then you map that superposition
state to the 1 state okay and for that
reason this operation is a fan known as
the square root of not actually Brian
Hayes is here wrote a whole column with
about the square root of not in the you
know uh some twenty years ago I think ok
so you know and in fact that the square
root of not you know contains a lot of
the intuition of you know as to what
quantum mechanics is about because you
know we can understand what's happening
here in terms of interference of
amplitudes okay so what's going on is
that the first time we apply this
operation zero gets mapped you know if
we just look at it as you know zero
which is the vector 1 comma zero or it
gets mapped to zero plus 1 over square
root of 2 okay and then we apply the
same operation a second time now quantum
mechanics is a linear theory ok so we
can think of an operation it's acting
separately on the 0 and the 1 parts of
the superposition ok
so then the zero part will just again
get mapped to zero plus one okay but the
catch is at the one part because this
entry here is is negative will get
mapped to minus zero plus one okay and
now to find the final amplitude for your
qubit being in the state zero you have
to add up the amplitudes for all the
ways that it could have been zero so
that includes this and this and as you
see those two amplitudes interfere
destructively and cancel each other out
and so that's why you never see zero
here you only ever see one okay because
that the outcomes leading to one have
reinforced each other all right so okay
but now you know at some point you have
to look at your system all right I
didn't see what it's doing so the rule
for measurement is that if you have
let's say a qubit and it's in the state
say alpha 0 plus beta 1 and let's say
you ask the question you know you just
you ask the system to make up its mind
already
right and just say are you zero or are
you 1 okay then the rule called the born
rule says it's going to tell you that
it's zero with probability absolute
value of alpha squared and that it's 1
with probability out absolute value of
beta squared and furthermore crucially
it sticks with its answer from then on
okay so if it tells you 1 and then you
ask it a second time what it is nothing
having changed in the interim then it
will again tell you what now you don't
get independent samples okay so so
famously measurement in quantum
mechanics is a destructive process right
you have to decide carefully when and
how you're going to measure because you
may never get another chance okay to
measure this you know this system okay
yeah so this is famously illustrated and
you know the double slit experiment okay
so you take a photon this is again my
view of what a photon looks like and you
send it you toward a screen with two
slits in it and then you look you you
count you you see where it ends up on a
second screen okay and you keep doing
this over and over with lots of photons
and you collect the statistics about
where it lands on the second screen and
you see this nice wavy interference
pattern that there's certain spots where
the photon likes to end up and between
them that's where it where it like where
it doesn't end up ok and
this is explained in terms of
constructive and destructive
interference between the two different
paths that the photon could have taken
to get to a particular place on the
second screen right and if if it arrives
here and all right you know arrives here
this way and arrives here at the point
that way with you know two amplitudes
that are in phase then that's a place
where the photons likely to end up if it
arrives the two different ways with
amplitudes that are out of phase then
it's not likely to end up there okay
however suppose you then look to say
well you know which slit is the damn
photon going through right then as soon
as you look then the interference
pattern disappears and you just see like
two gaussians right you just see that
you know either it goes through this one
or that one now I hasten to add that
there is nothing important here about it
being a conscious observer that's
looking right it could equally well be a
recording device you know a computer
which is you know or in fact any
physical object whatsoever you know
including some stray air molecules or
radiation or ever which is recording the
information or carrying away the
information about which slit the photon
went through okay as long as the
information leaks out then the
interference will not be observed okay
so another way to see what's going on is
in terms of entanglement so if you have
let's say two qubits and you just put
them next to each other then you know
you you form you know their joint state
using you know what's called the tensor
product rule okay it's exactly the same
thing as well that you would do with
classical probability distributions okay
you can just sort of expand this out and
just multiply these out so you get alpha
gamma 0 0 plus Alpha Delta 0 1 and so
forth ok that's called a product state
ok but very interestingly of course you
know there were some states of two
qubits let's say that cannot be factored
in that way ok uh the most famous of
which is this so-called I'm a PRN Stein
Podolski Rosen pair okay which is 0 0
plus 1 1 over the square root of 2 yeah
you can it's easy to prove that it
cannot be factorized like this ok so so
we call it entangled
okay so now what's what's called the the
deep mystery of quantum mechanics is you
know who or what decides when the
unitary evolution stops and when the
measurement part happens all right so
you know because if you think about it
right our measuring devices or you know
the atoms and our brains and so forth
ought to be governed by exactly the same
was as you know as the as the atoms or
the qubits that we're measuring right
and so you know everything you know
ought to just be you know governed by
unitary evolution sort of all the time
if you take you know if you take this
picture seriously so so who decides that
okay at this point we stop we halt the
unitary evolution and then we apply this
destructive and irreversible measurement
process right how did the laws of
physics know when you know when you know
what counts as a measurement okay so so
as it turns out you know you can tell a
story about what happens during a
measurement that only you know that just
treats it as a special case of ordinary
unitary evolution okay however if you
want to tell that story then you know
you're forced to say the following okay
that initially you have a qubit you know
like this and then you know that that
qubit is in a product state with you
know the whole rest of the of the
universe
okay and then as a result of an
interaction for example shining a laser
on the qubit you know to find out you
know what state is it in the the qubit
becomes entangled with various
information you know in the rest of the
world for example you know the the
what's written in the computer memory or
you know the position of a dial on the
recording device or the atoms in your
brain that are you know recording you
know having having seen the answer or
you know or whatever stray you know
radiation uh you know is then you know
is it's produced by all of that okay so
then you get an entangled state like
this and so so the picture is that that
actually this collapse never really
happens you know the the qubit just sort
of collapses to 0 where 2 1 sort of
relative to you right but really you
know if you wrote the full state then it
would look like this okay and so people
have argued about this for a long time
you know in the debate
could be summed up as many worlds or
many words I guess so you know so to
some people you know this is the
formalism is clearly telling you that
you know the universe splits into two
parallel copies and in one of them you
see the outcome zero and in the other
one you know you have a doppelganger who
sees the outcome one okay and you know
you can keep going on and you know maybe
you know one of you you know becomes a
bricklayer and the other one becomes a
you know a theoretical physicist or
whatever right so uh okay so you know
you have all these different life
histories okay other people say well
that's just you know empirically
meaningless because you know you never
see the other one anyway so you know we
might you know for gonna be hard-headed
scientists we should just ignore it and
say it doesn't figure into our
explanations okay personally you know I
tend to agree with every interpretation
of quantum mechanics to the extent that
it criticizes the other interpretations
so okay so all right so so now let me
let me tell you about a quantum
computing so so this was you know so
people sort of debated these sort of
philosophical issues for you know almost
the century but you know it was in the
1980s sort of people ask you know a very
a new kind of question that you know I
think gave you know an amazing new
perspective on these on these very old
issues and so what people started
noticing like Richard Fineman and like
David Deutsch is that if you um you know
we have a general entangled state not
just of two qubits but of let's say n
then to fully describe it you need a
vector of two to the N amplitudes okay
one for every possible configuration of
all n of the bits that's an enormous
amount of information for nature to be
keeping track of right the saying you
know for like a thousand particles that
well you know what off to the side
somewhere it needs like more scrap paper
than would fit in the whole observable
universe okay so you know this presents
an obvious practical problem if you're
trying to use a conventional computer to
simulate quantum mechanics okay and
chemists and physicists had known that
for a long time right I mean apparently
about 10% of the supercomputing cycles
that you know
are used by the the Department of Energy
or just for you know trying to simulate
quantum mechanics right solve the you
know the Schrodinger equation basically
that governs the unitary evolution okay
so but then Fineman you know I asked you
know in 1981 well you know if this is so
if you know we have to go to all this
work to simulate quantum mechanics well
then why not turn things around right
why not build a computer that itself you
know exploits the same you know
principles of superposition and
interference that we're having such a
hard time simulating okay so what would
such a computer be good for if we built
it well you know what's clear it would
be good for at least one thing namely
simulating quantum physics okay so what
wasn't clear what remained unclear for a
long time you know for a decade
afterward was whether such a computer
would also be good for anything else
okay so that's why it was a great
breakthrough in 1994 when Peter shor
showed that actually you know such a
computer could be used that the factor
integers in in polynomial time okay and
you know number theorist may care about
that a lot you know and there's other
people who also care about that okay so
all right so where are we in terms of
actually building quantum computers well
I'm very proud to report that after you
know what like almost twenty years and
you know more than a billion dollars
invested in this field by some estimates
a quantum computer has recently been
used successfully to factor 21 into
three times seven with high probability
this was this was using optics this was
using like this technique called qubit
recycling you know this was for a long
time it was they you know it was only 15
no now it's 21 okay so you know what
what is so you know this doesn't sound
very impressive what's what's the
difficulty here right well the huge
problem in trying to scale this up to a
reasonable size as you may have heard is
something called decoherence okay and
it's just directly relates to the fact
that I said earlier that that any
leakage of you know quantum information
into the extra
a world is going to just look like
measurement okay so if any sort of stray
particle comes through you know your
computer while it's computing and
carries away some you know information
about what state the computer was in
then it will be as if someone has gone
in and prematurely measured your
computer okay and prematurely collapsed
its state okay so this reason you know
quantum computation has been compared to
baking a souffle
I wouldn't know I've never baked a
souffle but uh you know apparently you
know if you if you you know open the
oven in the middle to look at how it's
doing and the thing collapses and then
you have to start over okay so you know
so so you have to keep the thing you
know incredibly well isolated from the
external environment and for this reason
quantum computing experiments often
involve cooling they're very close to
absolute zero okay but then at the same
time you need to be able to go in and
move the qubits around in order to do
the operations that you want
okay that's those twin requirements that
make things extremely hard now you know
they're they're they're such demanding
requirements that you know some people
many physicists thought in the 90s that
it could never work
what changed many many people's minds
was a huge discovery called a default
tolerance theorem which was a the I
guess combined work of many people you
know in the mid-1990s and what this says
is that you know if if you just get the
level of decoherence down to some finite
level not the zero okay but let's say to
you know like a 1% chance of an error
per qubit per gate operation time
originally it was like a 10 to the minus
6 chance okay but you know and since
then under depending what assumptions
you're willing to make people have you
know developed codes that can handle
larger and larger amounts of error right
and now under some you know aggressive
assumptions it's maybe even 1% or so
okay but you know if you have you know
if as long as your error is sort of
below some some critical value you can
actually
you know use very clever our correcting
codes to to to correct the errors you
know sort of as they're happening you
can do it faster than you're introducing
new errors okay so that's why you know
there's some threshold right this is
like the break-even point where you're
you know correcting errors faster than
you're creating new ones okay and
furthermore you can correct these errors
without measuring the information that
you know that would destroy your quantum
computation you only measure in a way to
tells you whether an error has occurred
or not and if so how to fix it okay so
you know it violated many people's
intuitions about you know about quantum
mechanics but you know it was you know a
theorem okay so you know and and you
know you could then you know do it like
an arbitrarily low on quantum
computation okay so I've I've compared
this threshold to like the the critical
mass for a nuclear weapon right
I mean before you're there it just you
know looks like a pile that's sitting
there it's doing nothing impressive
right so you know people say oh you know
you've only factor twenty one right how
about thirty five or something right but
you know that's sort of the wrong metric
right you know well once you get past
the threshold then you ought to be able
you know at least you know if the theory
is correct to scale things up you know
arbitrarily okay through as many qubits
as you want yeah yeah so that's that's a
big question so it actually there's a
trade-off between this threshold and a
number of extra qubits you need so
people have shown that you know you may
be able to handle at least numerical
simulations even like three percent
error but that's maybe like with a
million physical qubits per logical
qubit right and with you know as small
you know that with like a reasonable
size blow-up in the number of qubits
like you know maybe you know seven or
ten or something right then you know
then the the amount of error you can
deal with is currently much smaller
right yeah so so that is an issue right
you can have you can have what you can
have crosstalk so as you add more qubits
right they have you know you mostly want
to use their short range in
actions right but they also have
longer-range interactions and so with
each yet with each qubit you add then
you know there can be more and more
crosstalk you know so so if you look at
some of the the you know the designs
that have been put forward for quantum
computing architectures the qubits would
be like in different cubby holes and
they'd be taken out and moved around you
know using using lasers too you know
it's it just so that when two qubits are
supposed to interact then you bring
those two together right and otherwise
they're not close to each other okay and
actually you know some of you may know
that just this past year David Wineland
won the Nobel Prize in Physics
you know largely for for damaged perks
for experimentally demonstrating at
least you know a lot of these building
blocks that you can actually do this
stuff with ions that you can you know
move them around in a trap you know move
two of them close to each other move one
of them away you know have it talk to
another one and so forth you know at
least with three or four cubits okay so
yeah yeah it's entirely possible I mean
I mean first of all you know the fault
tolerance theorem because you know they
had to prove it as a theorem they had to
make like the most pessimistic
assumptions about the error right and
it's entirely plausible that you can be
you know much more aggressive with you
know in terms of you know what kind of
error you allow and that you know the
code will still work right but yeah
that's right that's right that's right
yeah so it's it's entirely possible that
they won't you know use it as a black
box but will you know open up the box
and take out the pieces that they did
but that they need to you know I mean
for them to ultimate question is just
you know does it work right so okay um
yeah so okay so so in fact you know if
you read you know many discussions about
you know the feasibility of quantum
computation they tend a focus almost
entirely on this fault tolerance theorem
and you know and the hypotheses behind
it you know
are they reasonable or they not okay you
know and it's understandable
you know I guess why they do that but
personally I take a different approach
okay um you know my focus is different
the reason I take it as obvious that if
quantum computing were impossible for
some fundamental reason then there would
have to be a deeper explanation for its
impossibility than just you know such
and such error correction schemes may
not work against every conceivable kind
of noise that people can think of okay
because if that were the case I would
want to push further and ask well well
why is that so you know um why is there
noise that's always going to kill you no
matter what you do okay so for example
many quantum computing skeptics have
pointed out that okay you know these
theorems at least initially you know
required the assumption that the noise
from one qubit to another was
uncorrelated okay that you've had
independent noise on each qubit okay you
know that's obviously not a perfectly
valid assumption you know you will have
correlations noise and today there are
fault power and theorems that handle you
know some amount of correlation in the
noise okay but you know but but maybe
the noise will be correlated in a way
that violates the assumptions of the
theorems okay and you know and in fact I
talked to some so I quantum computing
skeptics like alkali right and they view
their you know they what they think of
it in terms of you know nature is like a
cryptographic adversary right and if
there's any way that nature could design
the noise in order to kill the quantum
computation then that's what we should
assume that nature does right so um you
know yeah exactly exactly is it right
right so right so so it right so so it's
like it's like a world view where the
universe would have been specially
rigged to kill quantum computation right
and yeah right that's right that's right
that's right yeah
so you know but I would want to push
back further and say well you know then
you know there must be some deeper
explanation right there must be some way
just you know in terms of you know like
you know the laws of physics right in
terms of uniformly acting laws of
physics why I can understand how no
matter
what error correcting code I make up the
noise you know that there will be noise
that kills me
right it's to me it is not a satisfying
explanation if you have to you know say
well will you make up an error
correcting code and then I'll make up a
noise model that kills it okay so so
okay so you know as I've alluded to
there are you know visit some physicists
and computer scientists who remain you
know vocally convinced that scalable
quantum computing is completely
impossible so here are some of them you
know Gerard who famous physicist Gill
kalai I just mentioned we did gold right
Stephen Wolfram Robert a wiki and
yakonov these are also two physicists
Leonid Levin who some of us know so um
okay and perhaps a much larger number
who are sort of silently skeptical or
you know we're on on the sidelines or
something ok so you know one historical
analogy that I really like here is you
know to Charles Babbage right who had
this idea of building an analytical
engine you know in the 1820s and you
know and and it was you know very
natural the time for people to think
okay it's a very cute idea but you know
it's you know I don't know if they would
have put it exactly this way but you
know it's not going to scale and
practice okay because you know there's
always going to be you know you know
you've got all these gears these
mechanical things right there's you know
there's always going to be little
imperfections that will you know prevent
you from you know making ever making
this sort of more than a cute little toy
okay and the interesting thing is those
people were right for a hundred thirty
years okay that's you know think about
that right there is more than a century
in which those people could just
continue crowing you know that no one
had managed to do it and could just
continue to be right okay you know
eventually the technology caught up with
the theory of a required you know the
invention is first of the vacuum tube
and then of the transistor which are
things that Babbage could could could
not have even foreseen okay but yeah
okay oh so yeah yeah that's true
so actually von Neumann supplied the
theory of class
fault tolerance in the 1950s and that
was partly in response to people who
said that you know you know you know
even then the classical computing
wouldn't scale because you know you're
always gonna have some bugs in your
vacuum tube this may be literally bugs
you know insect nesting in them right
and you know and you put piece together
enough vacuum tubes it's never gonna
work right so you know he proved this
theorem saying you know you can actually
build a reliable classical computer out
of unreliable components you know
provided that the error rate is small
enough the quantum fault tolerance
theorem is really just the quantum
analog of von neumann's theorem okay so
um yeah yep that's true that's also true
so yeah so um you know it's you know I
think that there's like a whole I just
learned that there's like a whole genre
of science fiction that sort of takes
you know like is is about like like what
if you know like like Victorian
technology like became the future and so
you had like you know computers based on
you know Babbage style mechanical
devices and you know maybe that's an
alternate history okay and in our
history it seemed that the really make
it practical seem to require electronics
but okay so yeah all right so let me you
know outline sort of three possible sort
of skeptical positions and my responses
to them so you know this is like the
slide you know I guess after this slide
you can doze off if you want but so all
right the first skeptical position is
the one that says look the difficulties
in building a scalable quantum computer
are immense okay so this might not be
practical for a very long time and
sometimes people add and even if it
finally succeeds quantum computing will
have only limited applications okay
simulating quantum physics you know
breaking cryptography you know speeding
up combinatorial you know the solutions
to optimization problems somewhat you
know we're not exactly sure where by how
much okay maybe a few other things right
okay so my response to this position is
agreement this is all true okay so all
right the second sceptical position you
know
it's uh you know is the one that
interests me more okay this is uh you
know people who go further and they say
no quantum computing has to fail you
know even in principle even a thousand
or a million years from now okay because
you know sometimes they say it is you
know either it is likely that or it is
obvious that quantum mechanics itself is
wrong okay and you know to me the
reaction to that is kind of obvious you
know awesome right yeah that sounds like
a revolution in physics you know a
hundred times more exciting even than
building a quantum computer so you know
count me in right if building a quantum
computer you know and having it you know
understanding why it fails leads to the
discovery of you know a revision in
quantum mechanics right then you know we
couldn't be happier okay so all right so
now you know but then there's a third
position right and so many many of the
skeptics will push back and they'll say
no no no we don't think anything is
wrong with quantum mechanics you know
quantum mechanics is fine it's only
quantum computing that we object to okay
they say quantum you know you know
quantum mechanics is true but on top of
quantum mechanics there has to be some
kind of principle of unavoidable noise
or unavoidable decoherence or something
that will prevent you know scalable
quantum computing from ever working okay
and so my response to this third
objection is you know that that's also
you know really interesting and
wonderful and so what I want to know is
you know can you explain your principle
of unavoidable noise right how does it
work you know how can you derive it from
you know sort of underlying well you
know physical was and furthermore you
know can you show that it really does
kill quantum computing okay so um so so
to come back to guilt cholai right he's
you know very much advocates this path
number three you know when he believes
that there's a principle of unavoidable
noise you know right now there's just
two gaps in his argument he can't
explain why the principle is true if it
is true we can't explain why it would
make quantum computing impossible but he
sort of
mmm that's if that's also iffy but you
know but he's certain that you know you
know so okay so but the the thing that I
most want to know here is okay if you
have such a principle then can we turn
things on their head you know if it's
really totally impossible to use any
quantum system to solve a computational
problem you know say asymptotically fit
or exponentially faster than a classical
computer would solve it then does that
then suggest that there should be a an
efficient classical simulation for any
realistic quantum system for any of the
quantum systems occurring in nature okay
and if so what is that classical
simulation how does it work what does it
look like right and this is you know
something that sort of none of the
skeptics sort of even you know have
begun to answer right they're sort of
always sort of you know just focus on
killing quantum computing but then I
want to turn that around and make lemons
out of that lemonade and say well then
we should be able to use our existing
computers to simulate you know all the
possible quantum systems and yeah yeah
yes thank you that's absolutely possible
that I'm gonna count as a victory for
quantum computing okay if you can't do
Shor's algorithm but you can do
something else which is still hard to
simulate with a classical computer okay
then you know the sort of board you know
the that's enough to say that the
borders of the efficiently computable
are not what you know classical computer
science thought that they were okay and
so actually I'm going to come back to
that at the very end of my talk when I
will talk about you know exactly such a
you know a weak model of quantum
computing it doesn't let you do Shor's
algorithm we don't think but does let
you do something that we think is
classically hard right but but yeah that
is a possibility
yep okay that's also true and in fact
thank you Brian that leads to my point
of my fourth sceptical position the
that I won't address in this talk which
is which is the position that says that
you know um quantum computing yeah maybe
it can work but but but who cares
because everything that a quantum
computer can do can be efficiently
simulated by a classical computer and
thus there is an efficient classical
algorithm for factoring integers for
example okay and for you know simulating
quantum physics and doing all these
other things okay and the reason I'm not
going to address this is you know come
on really no you know I think you know
really that this this this would be a
different talk this is an orthogonal
issue okay so yeah okay all right so
yeah oh I'm sorry yes yeah well so so so
so it's hard for me to be very precise
because the people who argue this are
not very precise you know or or I don't
I don't fully understand what what
they're saying right but the idea would
be okay so here's an example suppose
that there were some fundamental
decoherence mechanism in nature right
that was always just sort of you know
measuring every cube you know God was
measuring every qubit you know at every
instant with some probability okay and
suppose that the rate at which that
happened was above the fault tolerance
threshold okay then that would be your
you know that would be an understandable
reason why we couldn't build a scalable
quantum computer so okay so so so the
point is you know like there seems to be
like a wall of the excluded middle right
either quantum systems can do something
that cannot be efficiently simulated by
classical computers or else they cannot
alright so you know if they can then you
know you have some kind of quantum
computer right if they can't then you
know then this sort of suggests that
there ought to be an efficient classical
simulator yeah okay good
okay so let me try to dig down and
identify what seemed like to me like the
common reasons for quantum computing
skepticism so many people you know just
think you know it just sounds too good
to be true or it sounds like science
fiction
I actually I have a a response to that
that I like which is that I don't think
any science fiction writer would ever
have made up a type of computer that can
do factoring and discrete logarithm but
that can't do n P complete problems I
think that that's beyond the imagination
of a science fiction writer so this you
know this is this sort of weird pattern
of we know of what you can and can't do
is you know okay fine okay so you know a
second reason I think is you know
annoyance at the you know sort of hype
and misrepresentations in the popular
press that you know then it is this this
you know super duper computer that's
gonna be on store shelves in five years
and it will do absolutely everything and
it will do it by trying all the
possibilities in parallel and instantly
finding the best one okay my response to
this is tell me about it I've been
trying to fight this for 10 years
but you know you know I try you know my
goal was not to sort of overcorrect in
the opposite direction I you know I want
to get it right ok so ok the third
reason is you know a belief in what
computer scientists know is the extended
church-turing thesis ok this is the idea
that you know any reasonable you know a
computation ought to be Simula bull us
with only polynomial blow-up and
resources by a deterministic Turing
machine and of course if quantum
computers you know could indeed be built
and a factoring was hard you know the
assuming factoring is hard then this
would violate the extended charge
storing thesis ok so you may say then
you know if ECT is my axiom then quantum
computing is is ruled out ok well so the
response to this course is well the the
extended church-turing thesis was never
anything but an encroachment of computer
science onto the turf of physics so you
know we don't get the cry
well if if physics then sort of counter
encroaches us okay so you know by the
way I'd say the original Church Touring
thesis about computability was was also
an encroachment of computer science onto
physics as turf except that in that case
you know we seem to have one okay okay
and then there's sort of some maybe more
interesting you know reason so so
there's sort of some some intuition you
know many people have that says that
look you know it's just not plausible
that a system of n particles would be
able to encode two to the N bits of
information you know any theory but just
telling us that has to be extravagant in
some way and it probably has you know
too many too much redundant information
in it and should be replaced by a better
theory where this is not true okay uh
you know and then of course there
there's you know I think often you'll
just find you know an underlying
skepticism of quantum mechanics itself
maybe even if modern physics in general
right but I think you know it's very
easy for people to you know hear about
you know black holes and quarks and you
know all kinds of you know they're you
know and just sort of treat it as you
know okay these are these are like fun
things to you know for someone to you
know think about or you know or write
science fiction about or something right
but then you know if it's actually if
this stuff is actually changing what can
be computed in polynomial time and it's
like oh you know well it's just gotten
real okay now we actually have to worry
about this and so it sort of puts people
face-to-face with some you know with
sort of aspects of physics that maybe
you know they wanted to sort of you know
they always wanted to sort of not not
take seriously but no yes that's right
that's another example yeah so okay
oh so so let me actually talk some more
about these these last two so so first
of all what can we say about the
argument that you know like like it's
it's just extravagant to be able to
store an exponential amount of
information and you know the state of a
mere n particles so you know so you may
say the following okay shouldn't we
search for a more reasonable theory you
know so a theory that would agree with
quantum mechanics on all the exists
experiments but you know it should have
you know nicer properties for example
you know using like polynomial resources
we should only be able to prepare a
singly exponential number of sort of
really different states not a doubly
exponential number right furthermore in
a volume of size n you know we should
only be able to reliably store and
retrieve a polynomial number of
classical bits not an exponential number
okay and then you know you may even say
you some more some fancier things like
you should be able to take an
exponential number of possible different
measurements on your state of n
particles and you should be able to
summarize the results of all of those
measurements using a string of only a
polynomial number of classical bits okay
and maybe even more ambitiously you
would like you know the states of n
particles to be packed learn above so to
be learner Bowl in the you know in the
in valiant sense okay with you know
using a number and amount of sample data
that scale is only polynomial a with the
number of particles and not
exponentially all right well so here is
my my newsflash such a theory actually
exists it's called quantum mechanics
okay so you know I think many people you
know like you know if you have this sort
of you know simplistic view of a you
know n qubits is just being this
exponentially long vector then you know
you you know you can you can be easily
led to think that this is just too
extravagant to be right but then you
know if you once you remember that
you're incredibly limited in how you can
actually act you know extract
information from a quantum system right
and you start formulating you know
operationally what do you mean by the
amount of information in this system
right and you say look I'm only gonna
count the information as being there if
I can reliably retrieve it okay and you
start you know imposing criteria like
that then you actually find that that in
some sense quantum mechanics is much
much more more reasonable yeah so they
they require they require proof so this
one this with this one this this one is
trivial yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so yes
yes they all do follow this one this one
this right that's right that's right no
further axioms involved you know yeah
this one is actually kind of trivial so
I'm just saying that you know although
there's a doubly exponential number of
states there's only a singly exponential
number that you can prepare by a
polynomial size circuit okay you know
this one is um basically whole evos
theorem right that bounds the amount of
quantum information and you know about
you know bounce the amount of classical
information that you can encode into a
quantum state in such a way that you can
reliably retrieve it okay and these two
were results of mine from you know 2004
this was my quantum post-selection
theorem and this was my quantum PAC
learning theorem okay good okay good so
all right so so now you know suppose
that scalable quantum computing is
impossible okay well then an obvious
question is what is the criterion that
tells us which quantum mechanical
experiments can be done and which ones
can't so all right so let me go through
a few possibilities so first one would
be maybe the issue is the amount the
amount of precision in the amplitudes
themselves okay and this is you know
Leonid Levin's view if you go to his
webpage right he has there's this essay
where he says the major problem with
quantum computing is the requirement
that basic quantum equations hold to
multi hundreth if not million these'
--ml positions where the significant
digits of the relevant amplitudes reside
we have never seen a physical law valid
to over a dozen decimals are quantum
amplitudes still complex numbers to such
accuracies or do they become quaternions
colored graphs or sick humor gremlins
okay
so you know I I appreciate the the
writing there's sort of an obvious
response to this which is uh take a
million photons let's say and put them
all through a 45 degree polarizing
filter right and then you know as by the
tensor product rule for my previous
slide in order to describe you know
that's an absolutely trivial experiment
to do right and yet to describe the
state produced as outcome right you're
going to have you know amplitudes that
are like 1 over 2 to the 500,000 ok so
you know it's so it seems obvious that
you know we can have some
systems in nature that involve
incredibly small amplitudes now that
shouldn't that shouldn't shock us right
if you took a classical coin and flipped
it you know a million times then you
know the probability of getting the
particular sequence of outcomes that you
saw is going to be like two to the minus
a million now does that mean that the
laws of probability will start breaking
down because the numbers are too small
right sorry I didn't say that I mean
this is this is actually this is fine I
mean as long as you don't have to keep
the photons confined if you can just
send them all out into space then they
could stay coherent for billions of
years yeah exactly you can even take the
same electrons and just you know look at
the looking sideways change the angle at
which you look at them right just the
fact that - yeah yeah yeah yeah but
summation off that no no that of course
yes yeah that's right that's exactly
what he's saying and now I'm responding
to that right I'm saying that you know
yes yes it is true that quantum
mechanics might break down at some you
know at some level or at some scale but
but now we can try to ask the further
question what could that level or scale
be okay and now I'm saying that it can't
be quite the thing that that liyan it is
suggesting here okay because you know to
produce tiny amplitudes you know at
least by itself is a trivial thing to
accomplish right so we can you know do
it routinely okay so
yeah you are actually going to get the
exactly this state CEO plus one I was
good oh well you know with some little
errors here but but that won't change
the smallness of the amplitudes or the
fact that the state will be
approximately this one yeah and I guess
you will still know them to some pretty
similar cues
yeah yeah yeah that's true you'll know
them like the multiplicative later very
high accuracy that's right okay so all
right so now we can push back is that
okay look we didn't really mean to say
you know the amp thing you know that's
the smallness of the amplitudes that's
the issue right of course you could have
product states of lots of qubits okay
but you know entanglement you know
between you know multiple qubits that we
think is an illusion all right well
there's an obvious response to that
which is this famous Bell inequality
that sort of demonstrated the you know
you know at least the most people the
reality of entanglement you know and you
know which has been violated and
experiments since since the 1980s okay
my favorite way to explain the bell in
equality is in terms of a game involving
you know two of the most you know I
guess familiar characters of computer
science Jennifer and Christian so yeah
that's right the violation the violation
is the good part for quantum mechanics
that's right Thank You Eddie this is the
violation so so the inequality is that
the certain game where they receive
these two inputs they have to produce
these outputs that satisfy this
condition and in a classical world where
the where they did not share entangled
particles but only you know classical
correlation one can prove that they
could only ever win this game three
quarters of the time and not more
however if they share entangled
particles then there's a strategy with
which they can win at eighty five
percent of the time okay so that's the
Bell inequality the fact that 0.85 is
more than 0.75 okay well yeah they have
what's called a non-local box ok all
right so yeah all right so so then you
know the next thing that people say is
well ok fine you know two or three
particles might be entangled but you
know a thousand particles could never be
entangled right so the issue was just
you know when you try to entangle two
many particles and this is where quantum
mechanics is going to break down this is
actually a very common position right I
just I hear it constantly like from okay
but it I I don't think it works either
because we have you know many many
experiments today that you know involve
you know in entanglement among you know
hundreds or thousands of particles and
that you know give precisely the
predictions of quantum mechanics ok for
example the double slit experiment that
I mentioned before is now been done not
only with photons but with buckyballs
with carbon sixty molecules and now with
actually much larger molecules even than
that like floppy you know biomolecules
right with you know hundreds of
particles in them okay and this whole
thing is in a superposition of you know
if two different places okay so yeah
well they're in a superposition of going
through one path and going through the
other so you can interpret that as you
know as an entangled state right yeah
you see the interference pattern yeah
yeah this is Island good group I'm in
Vienna been doing this yeah so you know
so high temp but your superconductors
like you know like this guy here okay
you know so you know they they
definitely involve you know sort of
coherent quantum effects you know among
you know many millions or billions of
particles right now it's it's true that
sort of these are not yet you know you
know maybe fair to call quantum
computers right because we can't control
the entanglement you know to make it do
the specific computations that we want
okay but what this is what what this
argument shows that the criterion the
thing that makes quantum computing
impossible cannot be that just that sort
of entanglement of you know among
thousands of particles is impossible
okay it kind of it can't be that it has
to be something else
so what's needed you know is what I
described in 2004 as a sure sure
separator okay so we need some principle
dividing line between the things that we
are sure that we can do and the things
that suffice for Shor's algorithm okay
so the question is what can the
separator be right and this is always my
question for the skeptics okay so you
know I in the same paper I tried to do
this gap
worked for them and proposed a candidate
which I called a tree size and so I said
look you know yeah maybe you know you
could have entanglement of thousands of
articles but you know what say we we we
ask for like what is the the smallest
formula by which you could express your
quantum state by using you know where
the the nodes would be Psalms and tensor
products right so you can take like a
tensor product of two states or you know
on disjoint sets of qubits or you can
take a linear combination of two states
on the same set of qubits okay and you
have to represent your state in this way
and then let's say you know that the
only states that are physically
reasonable are those states of n qubits
that can be represented by a tree of
this form that has only polynomial size
okay let's say that if the tree has to
be exponentially large then we're gonna
say that that state is physically
unreasonable right that would be you
know that seemed to me you know at least
a lot of the states people talked about
even highly entangled ones like
Schrodinger cats you know actually have
quite small trees right so this this
might seem like a reasonable criterion
okay but it turned out that this one
doesn't work either okay so if you just
look at states of like an identical
fermions or bosons you can actually use
a very beautiful result of Ron Russ from
2004 which were bounded what's called
the multilinear formula size of the
permanent and the determinant and show
that you need at least end to the login
gates in a multi linear formula for
these things okay in order to show that
any tree representing a state of just
identical non interacting fermions or
bosons would need to have size well
which is at least somewhat super
polynomial in the number of qubits all
right n to the log n okay and this
probably can also be proved you know
although I haven't done it for two and
three dimensional spin lattices there's
just you know like a lattice of qubits
with like a pair pairwise nearest
neighbor interactions alright that
probably also you know already has a
super polynomial tree size and that's
something that's you know very sort of
well studied and condensed matter
physics and you know seems to you know
obey quantum mechanics right so yeah
fact in all of these cases the true tree
size is probably exponential in n but
this is an open problem we don't yet
have the tools to prove that kind of
thing ok so I was going to discuss
something called epistemic hidden
variable theories which are another way
to try to have you know escaped quantum
mechanics and I have you know and some
recent results with my students and I
had about ruling out different epistemic
theories however since I'm running out
of time I think I'm going to skip this
part and I can come back to it later if
people want this was the you know
technical part of the talk okay you can
say yes technical stuff okay if you can
feel satisfied that it's there okay and
if you would know if you want I'll come
back to it later okay all right so let
me just you know gum briefly talked to
my last thing okay which is that you
know if you might wonder now if scalable
quantum computing is indeed possible are
there any experiments that could help
demonstrate that short of actually
building a completely general-purpose
quantum computer right could we just
have a special-purpose quantum computer
that just you know that just sort of
proves the point okay so you know
there's a you know or there's a few
possibilities for what kind of
experiments we could do we could try to
just keep one a single qubit coherent
for an extremely long time right now the
world record for doing that is about 15
minutes okay and ion traps right they
can keep a qubit coherent okay so you
know you can you know to really keep a
qubit coherent just one qubit coherent
for days or for weeks you might already
need quantum error correction okay you
know I mean if you want to keep the
qubit sort of localized in your lab
rather than traveling through
interstellar space okay then it can stay
coherent for billions of years okay so
um you know you can also try to build a
quantum computer which is specialized to
for adiabatic optimization right which
is just you know not Shor's algorithm
right but just sort of solving these you
know optimization problems fact you know
I've even I've heard something that
there's some company which has been
trying to do this you know actually
they've spent about a hundred million
dollars so far on doing
fortunately you know we don't you know
they they have a machine it does work
and it does have quantum effects at
least at some level the thing that I'd
say that we don't yet know is whether
the quantum effects are actually playing
a causal role in solving the problems
faster okay so you know the I I think
that the what what well they're they're
solving they're solving things you know
that was their special problem right
there
Ising spin minimization with their
special topology right they do you know
they do do it faster than you know
classical likes at solvers or whatever
or apparently faster right
but now uh yeah and I don't remember
exactly how much you know it's about
it's about 100 bits yeah right this is
well this is the question right yeah
right well this is right this is this is
this is the question right if they if
they put the same effort you know and
you know into just building a classical
thing would they have done it as well
right and and so one of the experiments
that many of us would like them to do is
to you know if they could just turn up
the decoherence in their device and show
that the performance degrades when they
do that that would be great all right
but you know they but unfortunately
they're set up is not designed for that
kind of experiment they say so so so so
I think that the ball was in their court
to really convincingly demonstrate this
okay so okay and then there's this a
boson sampling which Alex arkhipov and I
proposed a couple years ago and related
a restricted proposals so um those on
sampling you know is something for when
you only need your quantum computer to
overthrow the extended charge storing
thesis and not to do anything useful
okay we've got the solution for you okay
so so so the way yes yeah exactly so far
it doesn't work yeah so okay so the way
this this proposal works is I actually
gave a whole talk about this that MSR
before so I'll be brief but you know and
identical photons are generated they're
sent through a network of beam splitters
and then they're just measured at the
end to see where they they ended up
that's the only thing you can do with
this computer okay very very simple okay
and then the result of this you know the
thing you'll get out at the end
is just you know a sample from a
probability distribution right you know
the photons will not you know be in
quantum they won't you know do something
deterministic right sometimes they'll
arrive at these detect they're sometimes
at those okay and so you'll just get you
know a sample from a probability
distribution over possible detector
clicks okay and this distribution will
be very interesting it will have the
property that the probability piece of X
of each possible outcome X of the
experiment will be will correspond to
the permanent of some matrix you know
depending on X okay so if you have n
photons this will be an N by n matrix of
complex numbers okay so these two the
probability the amplitude will be the
permanent and the probability will be
the absolute square that of that
permanent okay now
the permanent of course is a famous a
sharp P complete problem so it's even
above np-complete okay this was the
result of a valiant in 1979 okay now you
know to be clear I'm not saying that
this set up lets us actually calculate
the permanent of a matrix of your choice
that would be too good to be true okay
that would mean we'd have a machine that
would solve np-complete problems and
even more for us okay this does
something different and much less useful
okay this samples from a probability
distribution you know that has over
matrices where matrices with large
permanence are somewhat more likely to
be sampled than matrices with small
permanence okay and so then what
arkhipov and I had the show was that
this task as useless as it apparently is
is nevertheless hard to simulate with a
classical computer okay under very
plausible assumptions okay so our result
was basically that a classical computer
cannot sample the same distribution in
polynomial time
unless P to the sharp p equals B P P to
the N P which if you don't know what
that means it's bad okay this would mean
that this polynomial hierarchy would
collapse okay which we don't want to
happen okay so you know now our main
conjecture is that this hardness of
sampling extends even to aprox an
approximate or noisy classical
simulation
you know and that leads to a beautiful a
complexity theoretic open problem in
order to understand the approximate case
what you really need to do you have to
prove that it a sharp be complete to
approximate the permanent you know even
of a matrix of independent Gaussian
entries okay and no you know in Clinton
classical complexity theory no one knows
how to do this yet we can prove that
it's sharp be complete to approximate
the permanent of an arbitrary matrix we
can prove that it's sharp be complete
- exactly compute the permanent of a
random matrix okay but to approximate
the permanent of a random matrix we
don't know okay but if you could prove
this then you know you would get that
even an approximate simulation of our
experiment with realistic noise would
already have this consequence of
collapsing the polynomial hierarchy that
would be great you don't you just are
for our purposes you just need evidence
that the problem is not in B P P to the
N P okay yeah oh yes okay you have to
quantify those suitably yeah one over
polynomial is basically that's right so
so there's a dialogue here right there
you know this is just if you just want
to handle like a little bit of noise
right and of course the experimentalists
right now have a huge amount of noise
all right and so you know we hope to you
know be able to eventually push our
hardness results to deal with even a
huge amount of noise but right but right
now even just to get them to handle a
little bit of noise you know is seems to
be pushing the frontiers and you know
clay of what people can do in classical
complexity theory alright so so yeah so
you know recently boson sampling was
actually demonstrated with three photons
and in some special examples with four
photons
this was the publicity photo that they
released this was done in University of
Queensland
so I'm actually on they were nice enough
to add me to their science paper doing
this you know three you know they they
experimentally verified that indeed the
amplitudes for three photons are given
by the permanent of a three by three
matrix and there are actually three
other groups that did it at the same
time
so actually the number of experimental
groups now exceeds the number of photons
so so you know so yeah so they're there
they're just beginning to scale this to
for up to four photons you know they
should be able to do you know like five
or six right but if this could be skip
right if this could be scaled to twenty
or thirty photons then I think at that
point it would probably be solving this
boson sampling problem faster than a
classical simulation of itself okay so
that would be sort of a very exciting
demonstration to be able to do now the
the main engineering problem the reason
why this is hard is that we don't have
very reliable sources of single photons
okay we don't have source you know we
have sources that sometimes generate a
photon and sometimes not sometimes
generate two photons you know right so
you need to just have your all your
sources reliably generate one photon at
the same time so that then they all
arrived at the detectors at the same
time and so you see all the interference
that you want okay that's the absolute
leena they did the because they they
they they only have to be there but when
I say at the same time I just mean to
within their wavelength so that you see
the interference okay of course you know
you know there's but you know I mean I
mean we owe ya know and of course it
doesn't have to be perfect it just needs
to be good enough that there's a
reasonable probability of getting you
know twenty photons arriving at your
detectors at the same time so that's the
goal
okay that's that this is the challenge
for the experimentalist whether they can
do this or not
alright so my conclusion I do I don't
know for sure that scalable quantum
computing is possible I'll be the first
to admit that but what I do know think
is that the popular framing of this
question gets things exactly backwards
believing that quantum computing can
work doesn't make you this sort of story
I'd visionary with this you know wild
dream it just makes you a scientific
conservative okay someone who believes
that quantum mechanics will continue to
be true okay you know and that our
current understanding of it is okay okay
doubting the quantum
computing work gooble Bart can work
doesn't make you a cautious realist it
makes you a scientific radical okay
someone who believes that our current
understanding of quantum mechanics must
be dramatically wrong in some way okay
and I wish more people would would
understand this point okay so you know I
think that the world has you know needs
both conservatives and radicals you know
and I tend to believe quantum computing
is possible but just because I have a
conservative temperament okay so I'll
stop there Thanks sorry sorry yeah so I
use the term radical loosely I mean you
know if you if you believe that that
there is you know that quantum mechanics
can you know you know works for all
existing experiments but they you know
there's it is only an approximation
there's some deeper theory that we have
yet to discover and you don't say
anything more about the deeper theory
but you know I don't think that itself
makes you a nut yeah yeah yeah yeah from
people who don't even understand the
existing experiments yeah that that does
make you a nut or at least uninformed oh
okay good that's an excellent question
yes that's an excellent question so I
mean in fact people are interested in
people are interested for a while in DNA
computing right which is an example of
this right people are very interested in
protein folding right as an amazing
natural computation that you know it's
quite hard to simulate with a with a
clip you know a digital computer ok all
of these examples are what a theoretical
computer scientist would regard as
possibly large constant factors
oops okay so these are you know ways of
sort of harnessing nature to do
classical computation or sort of
ordinary computation but with more
parallelism or with more processors you
know sort of you know working in tandem
right they are not ways that you know
you could violate this extended
church-turing thesis right because you
know they can still be sitting you know
he's asymptotically right and the limit
you know they can be it can be simulated
right and with with you know not an
amount of resources that grows only
polynomially with the size of your
system okay so you know I mean you can
see that clearly in the case of DNA
computing right people wanted to use it
to solve the Traveling Salesman problem
right but there was an obvious
scalability issue right that as you add
you know more cities right then the
number of you know strands of DNA that
you need grows exponentially until
there's not enough you know living
matter in the world you know yes okay so
that's an excellent question right so
you can you can wonder about what about
finding ground states of physical
systems right we're often it's an
np-hard problem and yet nature you know
seems to do it very easily okay there's
a catch there let me tell you the catch
okay the catch is that if you the
basically that the reason why nature can
find ground states easily is that most
of the instances sort of that arise in
nature are quite special or easy
instances okay so if you you know really
took seriously that finding a ground
state of like an icing spin glass is
np-hard right and if you designed an
icing spin glass such that finding its
ground state would then give you a proof
of the Riemann hypothesis let's say
right then we there is no reason to
believe that nature would it would
actually find the ground state right it
would get stuck and you know a
metastable what physicists would call
you know a metastable state right right
yeah so so no but this is actually a
known experimental fact in fact you know
in like with with soap with soap with
soap with soap up with yeah with well
okay well so so first of all I think
that actually random constraint
satisfaction problems are not nearly as
hard as people used to think that they
right yeah yeah yeah right yeah so I
mean I mean in in this case you know I
say we no we actually have sort of a
theory that tells us why you shouldn't
get an exponential speed-up this way
namely you know I could take we think we
understand the dynamics of the system
well enough that we could just put it
into a classical computer and just
simulate it step by step and that would
incur a large you know constant factor
blow up maybe right because the system
has a lot of parallelism right but it
wouldn't be an exponential blow up the
thing that's special about quantum
computing the thing that makes quantum
getting different is it the only way
that we know how to simulate and
entangled particles is using an
algorithm
you know a classical algorithm whose
complexity scales exponentially within
okay and that's the I think that that's
the only example in nature that has that
property
right